hello everybody and welcome to part 6 of
penumbra overture I figure this out
I'm not dumb this game is dumb and you
are all smart all of you smart smart
smart okay
now the secondary flow is obviously the
letter to which is the second one right
by one cooling system is the water steam
is the wavy lines going up as in steam
grease is the droplet main valve number
one pull the lever
BAM we're out of here okay I do this all
right secondary flow
bah bah bah bah bah am and what was the
next one it was cooling system excess
team all right cooling system ready go
excess team go go and the grease all
right and number one and I have a
destiny debate per chunk oh yeah
so smart I am smart look at that go look
at that go ah the graphics are amazing
that's enough of that Oh where's that
puzzle so easy know what level 109
hardness Oh lights oh it's so nice oh
yeah look at this
Dawg you still trapped good Oh which go
on their yard yeah yeah shut up no one
cares about you now we're making
progress now I go to the radio room
I get the powers all on I can talk to
someone give me the code for the door oh
shut up what we got here radio no not
quite right okay all right I'll take
your word for it poke it with a broom oh
yeah I got a broom [ __ ] come on
brant BAM Oh swept the [ __ ] out of you
yeah oh all right where am I going
what am i doing oh maybe it's the same
code as before 8 1 4 2 1 4 2 a 241
I don't know let me check let's see oh
it's nope nope aha 8 4 1 2 oh so smart
okay oh can you hear me hello yes I can
well I hope that your ears are working
better than your tongue so that you
might use them to listen to our work oh
my tongues fine shut up you have turned
on the light in the end beginning at
middle of the tunnel uh-huh some things
remain chocolate doc oh really by
Morrissey method I hope has helped but
for CT powers to the wall hold to the
right of the fence
oh go now there is no time to explain of
course not well in fact time is one of
the few things we have in abundance down
here
well surprises are spoiled by such Kathy
curiosity oh shut up [ __ ] you I don't
care
got it dad I know what you would you
write stupid jana fans him abba rate
okay bing-bing-bing-bing nope what did I
get the right did I mess it up
did I get up for one - nope - one for
eight got it
I shut up I hate you
Oh Ben oh ah what do i do what do i do
what do I do
maybe this mystery guys gonna talk to me
if I go to other other places the radio
room let me go and hear first
hi mystery guy talk to me no you remain
silent going in circles again I love
going in circles
anybody hello uh-huh
uh-huh oh wait a minute
Oh Morse code
too bad I don't know Morse code ah do
they honestly expect me to figure out
Morse code I don't even know I don't
even know I'm not gonna bother with it
if it comes down to that I will I will
for you guys I will go look up Morse
code learn it all of it and figure what
that says out if that's what it comes
down to I will do that oh there should
be a whole rap sir next
oh yeah beyond the fence thank you so
much oh maybe that's brute force my way
through this so strong what the hell was
that code like five digits yeah why was
that five subject not right here now
whatever okay all right Oh
once again I'm spiraling out of control
no one around to help me
mystery radio guy who probably knew the
code I bet he did jackass ah the jackets
gone back to the power room
oh man I love this I love this I'm just
I'm loving this game every minute of it
every minute I get stuck on a stupid
puzzle oh I haven't even seen a scary
thing not one scary thing nope not one
mm-hmm buh buh buh bah-bah maybe there
was another puzzle hidden in one of the
notes for men's warning 1272 maybe
that's it let's see well 782 oh wait a
minute
wasn't there oh oh oh ah ah yeah oh yeah
oh oh yeah oh yeah oh so smart oh oh and
I was totally gonna go learn Morse code
for you guys but I'm just my brain is
like exploding out of my skull for good
reasons not the bad ones
oh right all right what we got five two
five two five two three oh five two
three
wait no five two five two eight five two
three eight I got it I got it oh five
two three eight five two three eight
five two three eight five two three
eight five two three eight five two
three eight five two three eight five
two three eight all year all year five
two three eight oh yeah
five two three eight five two three
eight ah doggy get ready to be run ah no
no how was it no that was it oh oh no no
no no no no no no no Oh too smart for
this okay all right let's go again hang
on here ah hang on those are 500 that
was a seven five seven three eight let
me see one more time short short short
short short five long long short short
short short short short long young five
seven three
ah okay five seven three eight five one
three
everyone ignore what I did just a minute
ago everyone ignore it forget it purge
it from your memory five seven three
eight five seven three eight five seven
three eight I always get my sevens and
twos mixed up five seven three eight
five seven three eight five seven three
eight five seven three eight yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh so oh amazing look at me
oh yeah get out of here puppy don't
cares about you yeah get get gone oh you
see me up [ __ ] bring it on I'm up here
where are you you're down there yeah you
got nothing you got
an audio distributor yeah quick slide
haha okay I'll get up in go gonna feel
good go yeah yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah
I'm so so smart
yeah yeah I'm the best um I'm obviously
the best you little doggie need to deal
with it oh yeah Oh me my big brain on
huge muscles I'm so great oh well shut
up like something with a great many
small holes oh there's a horrible
analogy to perform some minor demolition
work so that we might one day meet again
uh-huh
for this - we shall require the use of a
large earth eating metal monster Jimena
sheen thirsty for juice from the place
where things are kids you mean gasoline
in the storage room
oh you're so stuck away you can call me
red I'll call you Billy
hey Billy I am sure you will agree your
billing rather similar to a card II know
your bill itching one more correctly I'm
calling you Billy
all right shut up all right I gotta
pause this here once again spent way too
much time on crap that you didn't need
to see so just purge all that in from
your memory and just like act as if I
knew exactly what I was doing okay I
will see you in part seven seven seven
seven I'll correct myself if I'm wrong
bye